there's no shortage of quality thriller
movies on Netflix especially if they
feature a Revenge story more star Jake
Gyllenhaal these films are the best of
the best and they've probably eluded
your watch list until now you might not
expect a prequel to a zombie movie to be
a lively comic Thriller but that's
exactly why you should check out Army of
Thieves much like its predecessor Army
of the Dead this mishmash of genres
depicts a group of criminals using the
zombie outbreak as a distraction to pull
off an epic Heist but this time the
spotlight is on The Lovable German safe
cracker Sebastian after being pulled
into an expert crew by jewel thief
Gwendolyn and falling for her in the
process Sebastian breaks into a series
of soon to be decommissioned safes
across Europe conflicts between
teammates and the threat of Interpol
keeps things Lively even if the
characters don't actually interact with
any zombies if you loved Army of the
Dead you'll probably love Army of
Thieves even though it wasn't also
directed by Zack Snyder I hope you too
will get great enjoyment out of it
like I do bad genius is another
inventive and wildly entertaining Heist
movie but this time there's an academic
twist at first Lynn a bright high school
student from a poor family gives away
test answers to her friend Grace for
free but she soon finds herself pulled
into an underground cottage industry of
cheating hidden God reduces her chances
for legitimate success but despite her
tumultuous conscience Len feels the need
to up the stakes with the help of
ambivalent Golden Boy Bank Lynn embarks
on an ambitious globetrotting plan to
memorize and distribute the answers to
an internationally standardized exam
with a 100 critic rating on Rotten
Tomatoes This 2017 Thriller from
Thailand is guaranteed to satisfy even
the pickiest of audiences a mistake
leads to a crime a crime leads to a
cover-up and a cover-up leads to a
conspiracy that's what happens in
caliber when an ordinary hunting trip in
Scotland turns tragic after
inexperienced Hunter Vaughn accidentally
kills a boy instead of the deer he was
aiming at his friend Marcus kills the
boy's vengeful father to protect them
soon the pressure is on as the pair are
forced to leave a Web of Lies in the
small town caliber examines the tensions
between rural people in the urban
tourists they need but loathe making for
a uniquely suspenseful and Unforgettable
experience if you can handle the intense
subject matter caliber is definitely
worth a watch next time you turn on
Netflix the sins of the past return with
the Vengeance in coming home in the dark
the horrific debut Thriller from
director James Ashcroft this uniquely
upsetting story starts with a familiar
premise as two armed robbers crash a
family's picnic but things are about to
go from bad to worse Alan the father has
a history with the criminals he worked
at the group home where the pair endured
extreme abuse during their childhoods
and he did nothing to stop it from
happening as The deep-seated Grudge
comes to the surface Alan is forced to
protect his family from the monsters he
apparently was complicit in creating the
well-crafted drama and suspense of
coming home in the dark make it as
thrilling as it is thoughtful and
morally complex there is a difference
between doing something and letting it
happen
it has to be a training session at a
survivalist Camp goes disastrously wrong
inverse time director Patrice
laliberte's 2020 film The Decline camp
director Elaine is convinced that
Society could easily collapse at any
moment and that everyone needs to know
how to survive on their own when one of
his students dies after a bomb
accidentally explodes Elaine is
determined to cover it up after all the
last thing he wants is the government's
attention on his Camp the rest of the
students don't necessarily agree and
soon the collapsing Society arrives in
miniature as they all scrambled to
survive a high-stakes conflict this
tightly paced Thriller makes great use
of its creative and entertaining premise
Emily bennetto has mountains of student
loan debt and the few jobs she's able to
find mostly gig work delivering food
barely keep her afloat there's no way
she can put a dent in everything she
owes until she falls in with a credit
card fraud ring which promises to net
her 200 for an hour's work Emily
gradually Embraces her Newfound
criminality and her attraction to Yusuf
who teaches her the ropes but a life of
crime is a dangerous one that's bound to
go wrong at some point Emily the
criminal provides a sharp relevant look
at the limited opportunities available
in the Contemporary economy and features
some wonderful lead work from its star
Aubry Plaza what do I have to do
kill someone
just kidding eye for an eye is a
ruthless Spanish language Revenge
Thriller that goes to some Dark Places
and it keeps the plot moving at a
breathless Pace aging drug lord Antonio
padine moves into a nursing home where
he deals with his physical Decline and
the constant demands of his son and
organization the old man forms a kind of
Friendship with Head Nurse Mario but
what he doesn't know is that he
irreparably damaged Mario's life a
number of years ago now that Mario has
the infamous padine at his Mercy he
intends to exact his revenge eye for an
eye is a brutal and surprising
meditation on the dangerous Allure of
payback one then you'll have a hard time
looking away from forgotten is an
enthralling mystery with twists after
agonizing twists jinzok Witnesses his
brothers kidnapping and when his brother
comes back Jinzo can't shake the nagging
sense that something is horribly wrong
his sense of disorientation goes deeper
and deeper until he begins to doubt that
his family is his family at all and when
he tries to convey his theory to the
police he's blindsided by another
shocking Revelation repressed memories
elaborate deceptions and family and
drama all intertwined to create a film
that will keep you guessing fans of
Korean Thrillers like old boy and
parasite should definitely give
forgotten a shot a weekend at the lake
goes off the rails when Jesse's husband
Gerald takes out a pair of handcuffs
just add a little spice Jesse doesn't
want to play at this particular fantasy
but Gerald refuses to take no for an
answer a struggle ensues and ends with
Gerald dead of a heart attack with Jesse
still handcuffed to their bed helplessly
stuck in the middle of nowhere and
frantically trying to think her way out
of the problem Jesse has to figure out
how to escape both her predicament which
includes a very hungry stray dog and a
possible Intruder and your own haunted
past Gerald's Game is agonizingly tense
and Carlo Gugino turns into spectacular
performance that's both vulnerable and
charismatic based on the Danish film of
the same name the guilty is full of
nail-biting suspense despite its
singular location one in particularly
distressing 9-1-1 call comes in Joe the
operator finds himself swept up into a
terrifying family tragedy craving
distraction from his own worries Joe
throws himself into finding Emily the
caller who claims to have been abducted
but as Joe tries to save Emily through
an endless series of phone calls and
favors he soon learns that the scenario
is far more complicated than he could
have imagined the real story May force
him to face some truths of his own the
guilty features the creative use of a
limited setting and it serves as a great
showcase for Jake Gyllenhaal's
considerable acting skills I get scared
of being alone too you know
and you know what I do when I'm lonely I
turn on the TV and I have company why
don't you go do that intense
contemporary and viscerally
uncomfortable the Polish Thriller the
hater provides an up close and personal
look at a young man who's made it his
life's mission to cultivate online
viciousness tamash has always been
unscrupulous and driven by obsessions
especially when it comes to Gabby the
girl he Longs for his Tendencies are
Amplified and refined once he starts his
new job running online smear campaigns
drumming up social unrest and broading
people towards violence when he Narrows
his sights to Gabby's family and the
politician they're championing the
personal and the professional Collide in
a shocking climax if you're a fan of
2014's Nightcrawler you'll probably find
something to enjoy in the hater in
Jeremy solnies hold the Dark Wolf expert
Russell Gore gets in over his head when
he travels to a remote part of Alaska a
woman named midora Sloane is claiming
that wolves are responsible for multiple
missing children but that doesn't align
with what Gore knows about wolf Behavior
what he finds after meeting midora and
her husband Vernon might not align with
what he knows about humans either
especially once a search uncovers their
son's body hold the dark is a
transfixing uncanny look at the depth
and strange draw of Darkness Jeffrey
Wright Riley Keough and Alexander
Skarsgard all provide fantastic
performances the darkest of humor is at
the heart of I care a lot The Vicious
Thriller in which the amoral Marla makes
her living framing elderly people as
incompetent and assuming control of
their assets It's a cruel and
nightmarish situation but she's always
able to make it at least technically
legal Marla unexpectedly meets her match
in Jennifer Peterson a wealthy woman who
doesn't seem to have any connections but
turns out to have a powerful criminal
son who takes it very personally when
his mother falls under Marla's control
the characters in this thrilling comedy
are brutally unlikable but thanks to the
acting skills of Rosamund Pike and Peter
Dinklage that never makes it any less
enjoyable equal parts funny and quietly
sad I don't feel at home in this world
anymore is the story of Ruth a nursing
assistant whose modest life is
interrupted by a burglary that the
police refuse to seriously investigate
Ruth teams up with her eccentric
neighbor Tony to try to get the job done
themselves and maybe find some emotional
catharsis along the way before solving
the theft can bring Ruth too much
closure however she accidentally finds
herself in deeper than she can handle
and she's soon being forced into
criminal activity of her own give this
one a watch if you're not sure whether
you want to laugh or cry or if you just
can't get enough Elijah Wood in your
life that's not me
leaving a BM in your yard that's not who
I am it's never totally clear what's
really going on in Charlie Kaufman's
mind-bending feature I'm thinking of
ending things as off-putting as it is
frightening this engrossing
psychological Thriller plays with time
Loops changing points of view and
surrealism to tell the story of a
nameless young woman and her boyfriend
who visit the man's desperately sad
parents for dinner during a snowstorm a
stopover at an all-night ice cream store
and an encounter with a high school
custodian suggests that some truly
bizarre things are at work in this
reality I'm thinking of ending things as
a movie as complex as it is fascinating
so don't expect to fully understand it
the first time around in level 16 Vivian
has grown up in a strange claustrophobic
all-girls school the administration
especially the icy Miss brixell tells
the girls many things they must be
obedient at all times they are outside
the school is poisonous and one day
they'll all be adopted by High Society
families but as Vivian enters the
titular level 16 the final stage of her
education she finds out that nothing at
the school is as it seems the vitamins
the girls are given are actually high
grade sedatives in both pixel and the
creepily affable Dr Miro have Sinister
plans for them level 16 is a smart
creative Thriller for fans of dystopian
sci-fi stories are buried within stories
in Tom Ford's nocturnal animals in which
a woman becomes engrossed in her
ex-husband's dark Thriller manuscript
years ago Susan left Edward to start a
new life with the more driven and
successful Hutton but it looks like she
might now regret that decision meanwhile
inside Edward's novel a man devotes
himself to Revenge after his family is
destroyed by a random act of violence
the two stories support each other in
Curious ways with each adding emotional
resonance in context to the other
sophisticated Bleak and Powerful
nocturnal animals is anchored by its
Unforgettable performances from Amy
Adams and Jake Gyllenhaal and an
oscar-nominated supporting role from
Michael Shannon what are we gonna do
it's a question of how serious you are
about seeing Justice Done A Love Affair
between two cellists Charlotte who had
to leave her training at a young age and
the successful Lizzie who still admires
her takes a dark turn in the Perfection
beautifully shot and deliciously Over
the Top This unpredictable horror
Thriller combines a jaw-dropping plot
with the two terrific lead performances
of Alison Williams and Logan Browning
the balance of power between Charlotte
and Lizzie is constantly shifting and
New Revelations about the situation
they're in continue to shock until the
very end who was playing whom and what's
really going on at this prestigious
musical Academy you'll just have to see
the Perfection for yourself to find out
the Swedish Thriller Red Dot is all
killer with no filler it's simple plot
and small cast proved to be more than
enough to hold viewers in suspense on
the eve of their first child's birth
Nadja and David attempt to reconnect by
going on a hiking trip in rural
Scandinavia and following some bizarre
interactions with the racist locals the
couple find themselves lost in the icy
woods they don't just have the cold to
worry about though a mysterious and
violent contingent is hunting them like
prey it's a desperate quest for survival
as Nadja and David's relationship is
tested like never before the stranger is
a gripping Thriller that looks at the
psychological toll that being undercover
for a long time would take on a person
Henry Teague the prime suspect in a
notorious abduction case finds himself
drawn into a well-connected criminal
Empire one that promises they can wipe
any slate clean what he doesn't know is
that Mark frame his closest friend in
the organization is an undercover cop
trying to get a confession out of Teague
by lulling him into a false sense of
security how far will frame go for a
confession that's the question at the
heart of this dense layered film
starring Joel Edgerton and Sean Harris
in timeshare Pedro Nava's family
vacation has gone unsettlingly awry
their Resort everfields has accidentally
double booked the Bungalow they're
staying in and they're stuck reluctantly
sharing space with strangers they don't
particularly trust that isn't the only
troubling aspect of the resort either
everfields exudes a certain kind of
corporate greed that makes everything
there seem slightly Askew just ask Andre
who works in the laundry and whose wife
has thrown her heart and soul into
selling everfield's timeshares he's at
his own weird and tumultuous experiences
with his longtime employer and things
might be getting worse dark comedy a
sense of building pressure and striking
cinematography help make timeshare an
intention grabbing Thriller found money
brings bad luck that's the central idea
in the 2018 Thriller the vanishing three
Lighthouse Keepers come across a washed
up corpse in his chest full of gold bars
but the opportunity of a lifetime starts
going wrong before they even get the
trunk open all too quickly bodies and
secrets start piling up soon it's no
longer a question of how they're going
to get away with their opportunistic
crime it's a question of how they're
going to live with themselves well
executed plot and an intriguing Vivid
setting combined to make the vanishing
of force to be reckoned with you allowed
to pay for what we've done
all of it xcot Matt Scudder takes a
private case that leads him into pitch
black territory in the gripping film A
Walk Among the Tombstones scudder's
mission is to find out who kidnapped
killed and dismembered a drug dealer's
wife it's a brutal crime that turns out
to be part of a series and hunting down
the cold-blooded men responsible leads
Scudder to the fresh kidnapping of a
different drug trafficker's teenage
daughter it's all Grim violent material
which makes the funny and tender
friendship between Scudder and his
homeless teenage assistant TJ a welcome
ray of light Liam Neeson shines as the
tough yet kind unlicensed investigator
in this gritty neo-noir when it comes to
claustrophobic suspense it's hard to
beat a submarine movie and the wolf's
call is one of the great recent examples
of the form Our Heroes the sharp-eared
Shanta Rod A Gifted sonar operator on a
French sub who winds up at the center of
complex and deception-filled Intrigue
that could wind up triggering a nuclear
war deciphering the significance of the
sounds he's hearing and connecting them
with new military intelligence is only
the first step in resolving things and
preventing millions of deaths the task
at hand demands courage and the
willingness to make sacrifices and shots
Rod will have to put his life on the
line to finish it